governor Gavin Newsom who's kind enough
to join us good morning governor how are
you good to be with you thanks for
having me on when did you get a I guess
a glimpse of this with LeBron was it
LeBron who opened your eyes to this no
it's my own experience playing baseball
got into college on a partial baseball
scholarship would not have gotten to a
four-year institution would ended up at
a junior college which would have been
the end of the world but my life has
changed because of a partial baseball
scholarship at Santa Clara and I
realized quickly this notion of student
athlete was absurd and and that was
baseball basketball and not football at
a Division one college so this
experience for me is is very raw very
real and it goes back decades how did
the relationship with LeBron James
strike up over the course of years I've
met him at a number of different
occasions and including on vacation of
all places and the Bahamas moons ago and
and he is you know been out front on
this he had co-produced with his partner
maverick a student athlete documentary a
number of years ago it sort of predates
all the issues around rich Paul and and
he's been at this for years so he's a
true believer and you sensed a different
kind of sincerity on this it wasn't
situational he's had a long-term core
belief system and and he expressed that
through his agent and we were able to
connect on this more formally and that
was when this idea just stated signing a
bill on his show as opposed to sitting
at my damn desk and the governor's
office what's been the reaction to this
what's the negative reaction to this
bill nervousness the unknown not just by
the NCUA
I mean to be fully candid a lot of very
close friends people that are supporters
people I support from Stanford
University USC UCLA the broader UC
system even the California State
University system 23 different campuses
their leadership all expressing concern
and then growing anxiety around title
nine issues which I think are mislead
but all of those are expressions of
doubt that what we're doing is the right
thing and I'm not ideological I I'm in
pursuit of fairness and justice but I am
not ideological about the application in
the implementation of this law what is
the goal of the bill its fairness I mean
the end of the day it's about
rebalancing the power and the power
structure now is dominantly in the hands
of a few in the institutions in the NCUA
themselves and I've just met too many
athletes I mean ad nauseam number of
athletes that have given up everything
body and mind in some cases to the sport
that they love and they were let down
they didn't necessarily complete their
degree if they did get a degree honestly
it wasn't the kind of quality experience
educational experience that others get
they never were fully integrated into
the campus environment and many of them
were living below the poverty line and
still are living below the poverty line
while their coaches were making millions
and millions of dollars and I don't
begrudge success but you know Country
Club memberships flying on private
planes getting a percentage of ticket
sales and jersey sales and these
athletes are getting nothing I I just
don't think that's right
I'm just trying to figure out how this
is gonna work of Anor because I know
that it can sound altruistic but you
know you follow the money and you you
know you find corruption it feels like
what's gonna prevent let's say a booster
at one of these schools saying you know
we're gonna pay we allocate a million
dollars for people to come over to my
car dealership and so you're going to
there's going to be incentive for you to
go to a school knowing hey I can make
money you know they got me penciled in
for a hundred to under starting
quarterback at Alabama I get to go make
a hundred thousand dollars every year
but what but there's gray area here and
this is a dark alley we're going down
though Gavin yeah I think we've been
down that dark alley I mean that's to
suggest the status quo doesn't
incentivize bad behavior and I think
that's foundationally that the the
problem look I I'm with look there's a
romanticism to amateurism I mean I I was
just you know I was watching a wonderful
video John wood and
and I mean I was just it one of my
favorites just for life lessons for
leadership lessons amazed makes me a
better governor
it's not about my love of sports john
wood and it's about love of life and
purpose and you know those days are over
with respect i'm analysts some of these
coaches my god they've completely lost
touch with that nc2 way the way they
talk sometimes i don't know they've
connected with that so i want to bring
to light a day what what we know is
already going on I want to move to a
more modern way of thinking I mean by
the way the Olympics have moved in this
direction hasn't destroyed the Olympic
movement people obviously are not
prohibited because they're professional
athletes to play in the Olympics they
can still get payment for name image
likeness
there are rules related to that and will
create rules of the road more
transparency and you in particular than
you'll hold folks to account my job is
to hold folks accountable subsequently
the NCUA to hold folks to account
against abuses there's so many questions
I got with this I I'm wondering if other
governors we saw Florida I think is
drawn up a bit by 2023 because Florida
some of these other states are moving up
the timeline to 2020 you have 2023
penciled in because of the same reasons
you guys have been having really
thoughtful conversations around this and
I imagine callers are going to come in
with things that we know we hadn't
frankly thought about then I think in
order to do something right you can't be
ideological you can't just dismiss the
arguments against what you're pursuing
and so our point is we want to give the
nc2 a time to do the right thing now let
me just say this I've been at this I was
at the EC Regents of which I've served
for nine years five years ago UC
Berkeley had the lowest graduation rates
in football UC Berkeley of all schools
in college football power five
conference and he's in the NCAA talked a
good game about how they were going to
move forward their forms they slow off
those reforms this is a more aggressive
approach because they have a deadline
here to get their act together and and
we want to give them time and we want to
give other states the time it's not just
by the way Florida New York says
Carolina we've seen Colorado Washington
state introduced legislation genies out
of the bottle reforms coming and it's
either the NCAA is going to get rolled
over by the courts or perhaps more
problematic for them public opinion
because public opinion with respect is
not on their side
we told the NCAA you were coming on we
offer them an opportunity to come on
they said that they would be watching
the show is there anything you would
like to say to mark emirate the
president of the NCAA I've known mark
for years I think he's a good decent and
honorable person and I don't say that
lightly and that's not just a politician
quote-unquote saying that I really
believe that I believe in his heart of
hearts he knows what the right thing to
do is and to his credit in May of this
year they put together a work group on
the issues related to named image and
likeness what I hope is that what he
comes out with next month does justice
to this moment and what I pray for him
and for the NCUA is that they go big
they go bold they forgive my language
step up their game and they acknowledge
this moment is an existential moment to
their business model and they do the
right things and think about the
athletes as the preeminent
responsibility of their organization and
not the institution's first not the
coaching staffs first in the athletic
departments but the students themselves
quote unquote these athletes and they
have their best interest at heart but
governor do you think the NCAA privately
is going well this lets us off the hook
we don't have to pay these players
nobody's gonna be saying hey the NCAA
you got to share all that money it
allows the NCAA to sort of get away with
what they've continued to get away with
keep all the revenue yeah and that's
that's if you accept this notion of
scarcity the scarcity mindset is there's
only so much money to go around and it's
a question of allocation versus the
framework of abundance where you think
this actually potentially will bring
more money into the system that would
reward everybody's talents and by the
way that's forgive me I took econ 101 at
Santa Clara
well I didn't just play baseball and
econ 101 reminds me a free enterprise
that's the whole fundamental notion of
the free market and by the way we had
unanimous support for those that voted
Republicans and Democrats in our
legislature social justice left the free
market right my belief is the abundance
mindset will take shape and the extent
that you're right the NCUA may look at
this actually quietly favorably I do
think it is a disruptive moment and they
have to meet it and if they tried to sue
and if they threaten as they have
threatened respectfully California to
pull NC to a access to our pac-12
conference into all of our schools
I think they'll lose the public opinion
and ultimately their moral authority
will wane as well as their formal
Authority and the whole system will
collapse governor thanks for joining us
by the way what kind of baseball player
were you at Santa Clara it was good for
six months and that was the end we'll
talk about all our nerves in surgery at
another time who had a bigger entourage
when you went to LeBrons show you or
LeBron you know I don't even want to
answer that because you know if you saw
my face would be a little red right now
governor thanks for joining us good luck
with this that's the governor California
Gavin Newsom for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
Direct TV stream for free on be our live
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]